and hilarious Edna and Jack Jack scene
and a return to syndromes Island are
just some of the scenes and stories that
ended up cut from Incredibles - yep Iike
a movie lovers it's Jan here and today
I'm revealing all the deleted scenes and
stories you never got to see in the
incredible sequel if this is your first
time here be sure to subscribe to get
all my Pixar videos and also leave a
comment about the movie for a chance to
win a cool Incredibles 2 Funko pop
spoilers ahead so take care if you've
not seen the film yet or add this video
to your watch later playlist a fantastic
fashion show scene featuring fan
favorites Edna mode and Jack Jack was
originally going to appear in the
incredible sequel in the deleted scene
Edna hosted a fashion show of her
designs and Jack Jack hilariously and
repeatedly interrupted the clothes and
Edna's fashion line called mode were
worn by models but still drew
inspiration from the powers of Edna's
favorite client superheroes for example
the see-through chiffon around this
models head was inspired by the look of
a force field of course we know only too
well about Edna's disdain for
supermodels from the first movie once I
think sober about them spoil stopping
little stick figures with puffy lips
looking only at themselves
I used to design for God's so the
fashion show was really a way of showing
that Edna was having to work with models
because supers who she really wanted to
work with were still illegal Incredibles
2 is Pixar's longest film to date and I
think this scene was cut because the
film was pretty packed already although
we do get some fantastic moments with
Edna and Jack Jack in the final film I'm
sure many fans would have liked to see
them together even more an earlier
version of the story that was eventually
discarded featured Helen donning a
disguise of a black wig and glasses and
taking on the fake named Gina Stryker so
she could go undercover and return to no
man is an island who was a mystery on
the island that she needed to figure out
and this could have been an interesting
alternate story especially if it had
uncovered some as yet unknown secrets
about either syndrome or Mirage who are
both based on the island in the first
movie the scene where Elastigirl uses
her powers to stop a runaway monorail
while simultaneously dealing with masses
of traffic and a family phone call was
initially going to be a lot less action
pache yes an early version of that
sequence had a last eagle bring the
train to a halt by simply pulling a
lever after she'd broken into the
control room
I'm really glad they explored other
options for that scene as if they've
gone with that initial idea it would
have been a lot less adrenaline fueled
and we wouldn't have seen as much of
that awesome elasticized chase sequence
which was a very cool moment of
Elastigirl displaying her solo
superpowers the opening sequence with
the Underminer went through many changes
during the movie's development at one
time it was going to feature enormous
clay golems bursting out of the ground
then that idea was thrown out and they
tried robots instead and even massive
earthworms all those scenarios ended up
being scrapped in favor of the runaway
tunneler because the idea was that the
sequence should work like a cold open
it was meant to quickly grab our
attention and get us on board for the
rest of the movie and all the additional
golems worms or robots could have
dragged the scene out too much another
aspect of Incredibles 2 that was altered
numerous times was its villain because
it just wasn't working that caused some
pretty big headaches for the filmmakers
especially when the movie's release date
was moved from 2019 up to 2018 which
meant they had much less time to try out
different scenarios to discover which
one worked best Incredibles 2 writer
director Brad Bird also had villain
issues on the first movie which had a
different big bad before syndrome
however Incredibles 2 was an even
tougher nut to crack and bird reckons he
discarded two and a half movies worth of
scenes along the way to creating the
final villain plot with screen slaver
initially actor Bob Odenkirk character
Winston Dever was going to be a shadier
more untrustworthy figure along the
lines of Odin Kirk's most famous role as
criminal lawyer Saul Goodman and
Breaking Bad in its prequel better call
Saul however Winston changed
significantly during bradford's rewrites
and recording sessions with Odenkirk
becoming a more innocent positive and
upbeat guy although Incredibles 2 picks
up right where the first film left off
at one point Brad Bird did briefly
consider aging up the pars and showing
them at completely different stages in
their lives in line with the 14 years
that have passed since the original
movie but ultimately bird was more keen
on following the example set by The
Simpsons which he used to work on as he
wanted to further explore the special
insight and
spective that each character had on
their particular period of life and he
also just wasn't interested in a
college-aged Jack Jack and I'm so glad
he made that decision as seeing an
incredibly super-powered baby was one of
my favorite parts of the movie Brad Bird
came up with a core idea for Incredibles
- in other words it's mum and dad role
reversal and its focus on Jack Jack's
powers around the time he finished the
original movie however numerous other
ideas the remaining storyline were
initially considered the first plot that
was pitched and which was greenlit by
Pixar involved artificial intelligence
the crew started working on this but
bird had to abandon it when he realized
it just didn't work
in fact Bird has said it scrapped AI
idea could make its way into another
movie so he hasn't yet given any further
details on it of course a I was already
featured in the first movie fired the
omni droid first then tried another
story which featured the pars enjoying
the showbiz spotlight speaking to cinema
blend the filmmakers explained that the
stakes in this story just weren't high
enough to create good drama and then it
made the family seem shallow eventually
as an internal Pixar screening it was
finding Nemo director Andrew Stanton who
suggested that given Helens reluctance
to rejoin the world of supers in the
first film the sequel needed to provide
a really strong reason for her to do
that and that led to the idea that
Elastigirl should be the poster person
for legalizing supers which combined
with the introduction of a brand new
villain the screens labor would properly
up the stakes for the new movie by the
way the gorgeous art of Incredibles -
hardback book also has some cool concept
art of outtakes from the movie including
a story where the Parr family travelled
to an icy frozen land and there's an
intriguing shot of Bob frozen under a
thick layer of ice so I'm thinking this
story might have involved Helen and the
family traveling there to rescue him
though that might have felt a bit too
similar to the first movie there are
also some very interesting characters
that were deleted from Incredibles too
including Frozone wife honey and I
reveal all the details in my next video
I'll link to it here and in the video
description as soon as it's ready now
are there any of these deleted scenes or
stories that you would have liked to
have seen in the movie and what was your
favorite moment in the finished film be
sure to comment and subscribe for a
chance to win an awesome Incredibles
Funko pop tap
to check out the top 30 Easter eggs you
might have missed in Incredibles 2 or
tap right for my full pixar playlist
where I explain all of Jack Jack's 17
powers and tap the bell to get all my
new videos as soon as I upload them if
you enjoyed this video a thumbs up is
always appreciated thanks for watching
and see you next time yippee-ki-yay
movie lovers